but it's quite interesting if you do if
you start talking about sex sexual
topics everything does become a double
entendre it just kind of happens that
way oh it gets harder oh you're shaping
it it depends whose hand is on it it's
kind of all of these things innocent in
their own way but framed correctly
naughty
bob bob saget come on in bob
one of the greatest ladies in show
business you guys know bob yeah
who's standing outside bob's a friend of
mine apparently he was walking by ah
you paid him to come and yeah
hey bob
i've never kissed you yeah
are you going to trap
do not catch me man do not catch me you
want to say
all right correct ferguson
dirtiest minds i can't believe to be in
the presence of these two amazing aren't
they women
spectacular to come here no no in case
we weren't funny enough you'd be here i
knew you'd be funny yeah that's oh
that's right ucb i knew the answer was
going to be yes
so yes yes and that's right now listen
if i thought things weren't going to be
funny the last person i would call
would be my friend bob look they're
giving you your own microphone wow this
is amazing and lily tomlin i i worship
you you've done so many wonderful things
for so many people
well i loved you forever
thank you i don't know what to say i was
supposed to be funny but i'm just
gloating on you yeah yeah and craig i'm
sitting on your lap so you know that's
all right you're you're gloating on me
in a different way
and i got up early so i'm i'm selfish
yeah what are you doing here bob this is
a big moment for america we're talking
about grace and frankie we're talking to
jane fonda and lily tomlin i know you
should have called my name i just wanted
to look from afar well you were looking
in the window you were like dustin
hoffman and the graduate banging on the
glass
no it's elaine it's a lot i know it's a
lane but i changed it to a little bit
bob it was a joke oh i forgot i don't
know humor has left me no come on six in
the morning nothing completely it's very
early and do you watch the grace and
frankie i i can't miss them i love that
i'm telling you it's the greatest show
well they're look at them they're
amazing they're jesus they are beautiful
american treasures if you want to go
home and work out
i'm leaving yeah all right okay are you
are you time for a while you want to get
lunch i would love that i'm going to go
to bed what time do you want to come
over i don't want to go to bed
[Applause]
this is really working out
i'm feeling a four-way happening
it sounds like all right
okay if that if that oh see that's
that's what happened to me my microphone
went like that
when bob said four-way
for older women that we make it's called
menage a moa
can i can i ask is it wrong to ask
because bob's thinking it anyway what's
the difference between a vibrator for
older women and a vibrator for well
one's a derrick that you would do street
concrete with oh and
you know i should have left when you say
goodbye yeah
no that is a good question
the print is big oh the print is big the
the the speeds light up in the dark
and the and the head
and the head moves very easily so you
don't have to overwork your arthritic
wrist okay because in the show i end up
with carpal tunnel syndrome
all i want to know is how to text you
i'm out i love you i love you all get
out i'll see you there buddy give me a
call all right
[Music]
[Music]
you